só acaba de deixar aqui uma entrada hoje
pegamos com celulares vai querer ser
aquilo quando vi um pé é um bundão olá
pessoal de quem fala andar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um game e hoje
trago jec um caso de investigação aqui
no hotel nem window de medo vou explicar
basicamente o que está a acontecer é que
neste quadro é uma coisa do paranormal e
porque gosto dele porque acho que não
deve ser nada mas voltou a gravar a
mesma porque pode acontecer alguma coisa
o window acha que é verdade e não acha
que é um fantasma são destaque no quadro
só que esse costume o theo é um facto
muito idoso de que nestas ondas a casa
da dona da casa da mãe não sabemos o que
vem dentro da casa da equipe não é um
vinho aqui do lado não vem dentro da
casa de banho e por acaso agora ainda
não aconteceu então de qualquer das
maneiras eu comecei a gravar porque pode
ser alguma coisa que esteja aqui então
se houve alguma coisa já é grave e não
está ajustado bom é o fantasma é o
fantasma da casa também possam 9 do
brasil e uma da manhã em portugal quanto
estava a fazer um vídeo de um só vai
estar hoje o vídeo portanto foi um vídeo
dele vocês vão ouvir o barulho e agora
não está acontecendo agora que o tom
elevado e é que não assumiu a equipe só
sabem se vocês forem novos aqui no canal
inscreva se aqui no botão embaixo ativo
em si nem para a identificação e eu não
sei o que irá acontecer com o youtube
mas meu junto em dois vídeos têm um gato
muito eu normalmente pego mais
visualizações nas primeiras horas que
isso não vá acontecer mesmo eu não sei
se é do conteúdo é pelo fato de eu estar
aqui no brasil e vocês não gostarem do
conteúdo que por não sair mas que não é
normal não é portanto se vocês
conseguirem partilhar este vídeo pessoal
conseguirem enviar tudo isso facilmente
eu agradeço muito mesmo deixou a sua
equipe põe partilhem isso ajuda muito
mesmo obrigar só briga entretanto e 9
barulhinho bom abrir o olho do igor
ainda o que taxou pesquisar aí tá
precisando de casas na ilha
mas na ualg exasperante na casa de banho
como assim a possibilidade de os
parceiros na água mas é o que eu acho
que essa é uma lei muito gatos d'água
tubos da água pode ser você nem de longe
daqui
leslie maioridade ou eu posso ter vindo
aqui né pergunta será que eu acho que
não é nas novas entradas ainda ontem que
sua entrada
eu ainda eu te diria que seria fazer
barulho mas não sozinho mas isso não me
deixa um pouco
achas não saibam reta então impede um
phantom eye to eye
olha aí pega agora o que vai acabar e
olha só tá bem escura que eu acho que no
ar condicionado ou ventilação assim mas
ela fez um samba juro eu gostei muito do
meu aiai só tem aqui lanterna vamos lá
ver que tem um tempo rápido lê só não se
conseguem ver uma história qualquer
coisa é isso e aquilo que é isso que
parece um rato meu filho que tem até um
pouquinho mas aqui em união
[Música]
sob um sol dentro eu não sei que isto é
grave o barulho de leite
eu acho que o flamengo pode ser o
esquema de funcionários
agora é só esperar um pouco mais eu
quero mesmo é ruim eu tenho que sair
também em frisco também fez chegar aqui
mas eu acho que eu não sei se vocês já
viram enquanto tentava tirar a câmera
ouvir isso muito bem
a lei traz
o barulho aqui e ouvir o outro ir bem
estranho meu eu falar sério problema de
estado
o filme 23 disto tudo o vôo o jovem não
sei se vocês não conseguir ouvir espera
espera espero que quando nós temos
orgulho vem daqui com nós temos aqui o
barulho vem do livro toca é o que eu
acho que consegui entender que eu sou pé
da porta o que como é que ela é como eu
já nem sei eu já nem sei nem a curto ou
nessa roda isso é muito grande
sinto que só acaba de deixar aqui uma
entrada falsa blitz vai querer ensinar
também vai tirar marcos só aqui é duro
que é o eu e estão aqui mas vai que ir
com roupa lei e isso tem um controle
maior
estamos tranquilos isso tem uma coisa é
você vai dar muito errado a série vai
dar muita gente não só vou ouvir esta
entrada
eles nem surge agora atua só abrir agora
esta parte de cima para 321 cuidado
cuidado
brincar é só o que eu vi um pm de
miranda kv plantei civil com quem se vê
mandei o kit europeu
é muita coincidência dois golos e agora
isso não é muita coincidência eu quero
ver o que que o olha aí é um pedro
criança juruá é um boneco portão
mulheres é um boneco pelo menos direção
boneco mas como então nem cria mantém se
ele não te fez o pessoal do bairro mas
começou a mulher que não quis logo daqui
muito moleque
ninguém mais um moleque mas pode ser uma
brincadeira sofre que desenvolve mac
mesmo entrado mas quero aqui fazer
brincadeira mesmo
daí que o que filmar isso é um boneco
mesmo é mesmo nem colocar eu vou encarar
esta partida com a cabeça e vocês vão
consolidar ainda mais do que manter isso
enquanto o hospital dentro da mesma
linha um bebê
mesmo que fique pouco as coisas
ae o catar tem medo que haja bichos e
que em poucas horas ficar mais barato
porque é mais capaz graves assim
centavos fechando a subir e agora não
sei que só vejam só que tal é
fundamental e é isso que espero não ser
que sua obrigação agora é em dobro do
brasil vai fazer discutir eu não sei que
está a passar mas isso é muito engraçado
porque há aqui um bebê pode ter ganho um
pouco cansado a gente é normal a
situação atual é isso aí
embora eu vou ganhar isso nem mesmo o
sol deu a cara do meu deus proteja esta
cara dela meu eu que agora sim quero ver
a cara mas não vamos reiniciar do boca
para eu voltar eu estava preto e preto
meu é muito pesada
olha aí mas é que breca item mergulho
preto curtinho que isso tudo muito
rápido e tem muita piada tem muita piada
era vulgar vulgar vulgar lei
olha essa boneca que isso olhei sono por
isso
sinto muito não via mais força na bola e
tudo que isso lhe surdo nem sempre em
cadeia face se não eu não fiz isso é
brincadeira
não não fiz choro só isso é muito
assustador e eu não fui eu não fui eu
[Música]
danço
foi alguém que um tio e meu tipo isto é
possível e acho que não tem nada só
vocês conseguem virar uma coisa se
conseguir alguma coisa comenta e estou a
ver que ela achar mais oportuno não
tinham isso não diz ela não é a hora aí
né é a marca do planeta é a marca do
planeta assim que não sabe falar em
controle e isso aqui é só uma que
pintava pirata muito estudar mesmo assim
mas a brincadeira só não faz direito
como é que acho que foi ali parar mas
existe uma brincadeira que alguém fez
aqui em nota o tipo escolheram esta
boneca em cima das pessoas só o legista
é muito estranho nome toca só nela não
toco nada é um bairro é boneco é uma
lição e essas coisas lá com isso olha só
tá male só chamar lhe são imputados mais
que o barco não pôde ser um brinquedo
isso é um brinquedo tem um só nisso
saibam de caixa aqui quando ela está
aqui também jabs só tem praia
só não sei que vai acontecer aqui mas
infelizmente os números continuam
portanto eu vou continuar o esbulho já
te ir embora no quarto e acabamos por 10
uma boneca com uma primeira mão de sua
só comentei o que vocês acham foi o
windows assunto foi alguém a fazer isso
acho que fui eu montei esta coisa toda
será que fui eu
não por acaso não eu estava te deu pra
fazer uma boa idéia
eu não fui eu juro acha que fui eu tava
vendo meu pintar um movimento só
comentei que vocês acham que eu não sei
que no canal e ainda bem que eu comecei
a gravar na época que eu procuro ser uma
nunca e é isso fique bem até a próxima